You're up!
Let's come together!
It'll Papa, it'll Papa It's now or never!
I love you all!
It'll Papa, it'll Papa Welcome in Europe-a-bub Agriculture
till it don't dry It'll Papa, it'll Papa Welcome in
Europe-a-bub, back here till it'll dry It'll Papa, it'll
Papa You talk to my friends and friends I'm named a Beinen
If you fuck in the Netherlands I have a look, I have a visa,
no doubt to buy you to say I'm just in the bus, no polo,
I'll try no bolein I have no help, no tari, do you use me
like my fantasy I can earn a rojo please, up my scene, I'll
show please I've been like all this quite, but how it's a
tight Do you see me every day, I'll rise, but the world is
by me Welcome in Europa, welcome to Europa, welcome to
Europa, Welcome in Europa, back here to Europa,
I am in Germany, but I am in Italy, but I'm not Dr. DuPine.
I'm in flux and then myself.
What the hell?
I need my help.
Yeah, I need my help.
I need some cargo.
I need some fish and chips.
I need a pile.
Yeah, no.
I don't know what that is.
Zotero radio on.
A horse show mom and papa.
Ute Zalni, stop in Toots and Sere.
Yeah, yeah, that dootie hootie.
Welcome in Europa.
Back here till it do try.
It'll papa, it'll papa.
Welcome in Europa.
Back here till it do try.
It'll papa, it'll papa.
Uloa, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Uloa, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, I don't care
who you are.
I don't care where you come from.
All we got is this moment.
So let's come together, baby.
Welcome in Europa, Yongis.
Hey!
Uh-uh!
On the other one day, I'm not a man since My father's in my
order They're in the water, they're on the I miss you every
day, it's like I'm sticking Please, flaustin' See, no, we're
pa, I keep no ya, hello, state Hello, state